welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and today I'm breaking
down what if season 2 episode 3 what if
happy Hogan Saved Christmas Eric is on
patern Le but he helped me write this
breakdown as the full new Rockstar team
is chipping away at these like elves to
breakdown this season in this video I'm
going to take you scene by scene through
this DieHard tribute to explain all the
Easter eggs animation details and one
Marvel Comic character established to be
in the MCU by this episode so ho ho ho
now I have a breakdown so yipp kayay
mother fabos let's do this over the
opening Marvel Studios Fan Fair painted
with brush Strokes they composed a
holiday rendition of Michael Gino's
theme music which now sounds like the 12
Days of Christmas this carol comes back
when Hulk happy fights Justin hammer and
the Hulkbuster armor The Watcher fades
in behind falling snow inside an
Avengers Tower snow globe this is the
specific era of tower that we first saw
in Age of Ultron with the taller glass
enclosed multi-tier Penthouse built out
over The quinjet Landing Pad the image
of a New York skyscraper cross
dissolving into a snow globe Echoes John
favro shot of the Empire State Building
in the final minutes of Elf which Eric
broke down in another video I'll put it
down here it's it's it's on our Channel
go watch it this episode of what if
takes us back to feos Roots as a
Christmas softy just like me the Watcher
quotes the poem toward the Night Before
Christmas AKA a visit from St Nicholas
published anonymously in 1823 and later
attributed to Clem Clark Moore in 1837
but the Watcher doesn't stick with the
rhyme scheme he just says TW the night
before Christmas and all through the
town The Avengers were fighting a brand
new superpower he could have said it was
the night before Christmas and at this
late hour The Avengers were fighting a
brand new superpower
period cut the cameras cut the cameras
but notice that the Watcher doesn't call
this purple baddy a villain just a
superpower because we later learned this
is Happy Hogan and he's not a villain
Thor stocking drops because it's already
on fire from the fight then Tony asks
where's Thor Thor was off world for most
of the episode and only drops in at the
very end the stockings include Maria
Darcy Clint Thor Tony Pepper G roie
Steve happy and then the big green one
for Bruce and Iron Man 3 Tony hang
similar stockings in his Malibu mansion
including one for Jarvis and Visions
colors but doesn't include Jarvis here
or Sam Wilson we'll come back to that
maybe maybe maybe we'll come back to
this this episode seems to take place in
Christmas 2014 after Tony's Malibu
mansion was destroyed in Iron Man 3 and
just a few months before Age of Ultron
that would explain why Tony's iron
Legion drones which Ultron hijacks in
that film are only now starting to go
online later on Maria Hill says they
needed to celebrate after the year we've
had and I think that's referring to
Shield's trouble with Hydra and the
scandal of project Insight happy stands
in a triangular full of the Avengers a
logo of the tower as iron Legion drones
place a large Santa hat on the a Happy's
also right beneath the mistletoe so get
this man and UT May Darcy Lewis radio a
Happy Spirit one to Puffin two Eric is
obsessed with birds and points out that
all 12 of The 12 Days of Christmas
refers to birds so it's not just 184
Birds total you also have to include the
drumers drumming for drummer bird aka
the roughed Grouse and Pipers piping for
sandpipers and Lords ladies maids and
Rings all have bird equivalent so it's
actually 239 birds in total Jesus Christ
get your bird totals right so Darcy
using bird codeen names is consistent
with the Aven theme she gives Happy Puff
and to because Bernard in accounting as
Puffin one and puffins are adorable
squat birds and happy kind of looks like
one she offers him turkey one Flamingo 6
or parakeet no one has claimed turkey
because it's what you eat on Christmas
happy implies Darcy is here for college
credit so after the events of Thor the
Dark World she's doing the Stark
internship the same one Peter Parker
says he's doing as his cover story he
sends her out for Marino Cherry saying
Tony needs them for his hot totties hot
totties are only hot water whiskey honey
and lemon cherries are used in an old
fashion my dude Maria Hill greets happy
this would be after the events of
Captain America Winter Soldier in which
Nick Fury went off the gridge she wears
a snowman pin which is fitting since her
character got fridged in secret
Invasion damn Darcy passes Justin Hammer
Sam Rockwell returning to voice the
character with his grunt Sergey and
Rusty Hammer was the villain of Iron Man
2 Tony's rival the head of hammer
Industries we last saw him in the short
film all hail the king as an inmate at
Seagate prison along with Trevor
Slattery who was extracted by the 10
rings The Watcher reframes this as a
story of how Justin and Hammer sold
Christmas making Hammer the Grinch of
the story most episodes of what if turn
on a specific historical Lynch pin but
in this case it's really what if just a
hammer tried to steal Hulk blood from
Avengers tower on Christmas it's clear
they just wanted to do a Die Hard
scenario and I'm not compl we return to
Hammer's weapon expo from Iron Man 2
when he danced out on the stage Sam
Rockwell has a thing for dancing in many
of his films and this episode later pays
homage to that Trope we also see hammer
and Seagate reading a magazine article
about Tony Stark in which Tony must have
alluded to as attempt to create Hulk
antigen serum maybe Tony did this in an
interview to try to reassure the public
that he had Hulk under control we know
at this point Tony was working on the
Hulkbuster armor hammer and this guy
crashed the party with machine guns just
like Hans grber and his men in Die Hard
storming nakatomi Tower I love this one
over dramatic caterer right here we're
going to die we're all going to die
Hamry says when he was 7 years old he
wanted a Red Rider BB gun and it got his
tongue stuck to a pole he's taking this
from A Christmas Story and someone says
you'll shoot your eye out that film
Stars Peter Billingsley a filmmaker and
longtime collaborator to John favro
playing Mingming and elf and in MCU
William G Reva the Stark engineer OB I
stain yells at and a member of Team
Mysterio and Spider-Man far from home
Happy says this he unplugged Jarvis for
5 minutes the whole building collapses
this is essentially what happens in Age
of Ultron Jarvis takes a nap and Ultron
just takes over and then Darcy sings
Good Queen Darcy last look down on the
Feast of Steve Rogers instead of on the
Feast of Steven she makes it Steve
Rogers where is Hans group pretended to
be a terrorist as a cover story to steal
Bank bonds From the Vault Justin Hammer
hijacks the iron Legion to serve his
true goal gamma irradiated antigen serum
AKA The Hulk blood to turn himself into
a Hulk Hammer scheme is the same
intelligencia plot that She-Hulk made
fun of and reccon because she thought it
was super freaking lame cuz it is Maria
Hill is surprised Hammer doesn't raid
the Armory and she's right the iron
Legion alone is way more powerful of a
tool than hammer becoming a Hulk happy
confirms Tony was working on a way to
stabilize Hulk's power they complete the
process during the blip resulting in
smart Hulk an Avengers endgame and in
she hope we learn they build a gamma lab
in Mexico Hammer says this I knew I
should have gone with the sovian team at
this point in history sovia was an
unstable War torn region where Hydra set
up a base and was currently
experimenting on Wanda and Petro
maximoff happy leaps to an air vent in
An Elevator Shaft and then slides back
before crawling forward he says this
throw a holiday party it'll be fun Tony
said what could go wrong John mlan makes
a similar jump slide and remark in Die
Hard he says this come out to the coast
we'll get together have a few left this
if you spent Elementary School
practicing the Vulcan salute like me I'm
still trying and now you're looking for
your nerd shelf to boldly go where no
Shelf has gone before you're probably
ready for the new Star Trek model kit
from fanhome fanhome is a brand
dedicated to developing unique
Collections and buildup models from Star
Trek Universal Star Wars Marvel and more
a fan home subscription gets you
magazines loaded with trivia and stories
about your favorite fandom but also
everything you need to build your very
own USS Enterprise which I know you guys
need to do fom's Enterprise model is
over 28 in long and 8 in wide it's made
from the metal and ABS plastic which
means it's dirty so it won't fall apart
when your friends come over and want to
see how the windows and engines light up
I'm looking at you Ashley with a fan
home subscription you get new parts
every month plus instructions on how to
put everything together so you can build
your model up bit by bit rather than
overwhelmed trying to do it all at once
on top of that you'll also get a Star
Trek mug t-shirt binder and screw box
God give me this a fanhome subscription
is the perfect way to make your
collection stand out to get started just
click the link below in the description
happy hangs upside down from a vanent
his Walky slips out and he catches it
just in time just like Ethan Hunt in the
first mission impossible catching his
drop of sweat happy finds a confetti
Arrow oh come on Tony you're booking
Hawkeye out for birthday parties now
this reminds us the variety of arrows
that Clint had in the Hawkeye series
including the Pim Tech arrow that can
resize things happy accidentally injects
his own leg with Hulk blood causing just
his leg at first to Hulk out purple
happy now as to hobble around with one
bare purple Hulk foot so in a way it's
kind of like John mlan having to be
barefoot and die hard despite Tony
working out of Avengers Tower he keeps
ining I love La mug from their time on
the west coast also in the room is a
replica cap Shield cap mask and posters
of the Avengers and holiday costumes
because it seems like Tony made everyone
do Christmas charity work and Natasha
ended up on a mission happy Scrolls
through his phone and among the contacts
we see a Bradley for AC Bradley head
writer of what if Series M chony for
Matthew chony a what if writer C
Everhart for Christine everheart the
magazine reporter whom Tony hooked up
with later turned wh anchor G Fisher for
Graham Fisher and edor for series N Fury
for Nick Fury M Hill for Maria Hill H
Keener for Haley Keener the Tennessee
kid from Iron Man 3 you remember him C
Klein for Cameron Klein The Shield Tech
who was loyal to cap during the winter
soldier and later helps Fury pilot the
hell carrier in Age of Ultron sley a nod
to sanley of course D Lewis Darcy Lewis
a she made it into his contacts Jay
Lincoln for Janice Lincoln the new
Beetle daughter of Tombstone that's an
interesting one because Beetle has
otherwise never been established in the
MCU hey yo PE pots for pepper pots Jay
rhs for roie S Rogers for Steve Rogers
GT Ross for General Thaddius Ross n
Romanov for Natasha Romanov T Stark for
Tony Stark and S Wilson for Sam Wilson
above a performance of The Nutcracker
Natasha's being held at gunpoint I'm
being held at gunpoint by a former Hydra
agent with 17 kills 18 kills you forgot
Nigeria oh that was you show off there's
that number 17 in MCU again 17 was one
of the win Soldier activation words
among several others writers use it
because it's three syllables and it
rhythmically sounds like a lot of
something but also not too many of
anything Tony is playing Santa at a
charity event soccer mom's tug at Steve
Rogers and I love the one who creeps up
his leg From Below meanwhile in another
part of the department store kids mob
Bruce and Clint for the last Iron Man
action figure no one wants Hawkeye
action figures oh this is horrible
they're fully stocked marked down from
15% off to 25% off even Clint's kids
don't want an action figure of him
Bruce's Christmas sweater reads
chemistry so so fny and and then Bruce
says this think we need to wrap this up
Sun's getting real low pal like super
winter Sol is kind of low by now Bruce
and Natasha have come up with their calm
down method you know Darcy tries to
remember Die Hard asking if this is
Conair or under siege but she remembers
that Reginal V Johnson played the cop
who talks to John mlan from the outside
Reginal V Johnson that's what you
remember from the movie just like Darcy
leaving the store with cherri's when we
first met pal and die hard he's leaving
the store with snacks happy tries to
hide in the Avenger Taylor Workshop the
fabric rols include oranza spandex
leather and Tweed happy grabs the
Spandex and Dives out the window
swinging down into the floor below just
like John mlan does with the fire hose
and die hard happy completes his
transformation the music is a nightmare
version of Jingle
[Music]
Bells Hulk Cappy is an Avengers Towers
gym with punching bags presumably so cap
can do his workouts there Hulk Cappy
punches the bag off the chain remember
happy Hogan was a former boxer in the
comics I also think he was found boxing
Natasha in the movie and well he gets
his ass kicked Darcy unlocks the main
frame in the sub basement and we hear
Beethoven's o to Joy which was the music
in Die Hard When Hans gruber's crew
finally unlocked the Vault Darcy looks
for a backup Jarvis all right here we go
boss we got a Friday a Wadsworth an
Edith 1.0 Friday is Tony's AI in Age of
Ultron replacing Jarvis and not to his
girl Friday e stands for even dead I'm
the hero and it was the AI in the
glasses that Tony gives Peter Parker and
far from home this means that all the
way back in 2014 Tony was working on an
AI that he could transfer over to his
successor via glasses at first I thought
wner was named after wner Von braa but
it's actually a voice similar to verer
Herzog voice in this episode by Red
School actor Ross marand happy sends up
the elevator with a mannequin with a
sign that says Let It Snow jabbed with a
confetti Arrow this is notd to John mlan
sending down the corpse of one of Hans
gruber's men with ho ho ho now have a
machine gun on his clothes Hulk happy
frees Maria and Darcy from the penthouse
and then clobbers a bunch of iron leader
sentries in the hall one tries to crawl
away from him and he grabs them by his
legs and rips him in half kind of like
when Wanda kills all the Ultron
centuries of Multiverse of Madness and
the fact that these have black fluid
that looks like their real blood makes
me feel horrible for them like it ew
it's gross it's Justin Hammer says this
Famous Last Words Hulk Cogan I just
didn't want to call him Hulk Hogan
because this man deserves better than
this Tony Veronica hovercraft from Age
of Ultron deploys the pieces of the mark
44 Hulkbuster armor while they duke it
out Darcy bypasses the computer freeze
with the control alt
delete huh that actually worked little
trick I picked up in turning for the
Culver University it Department the
Culver computer lab is where Edward
Norton Bruce Banner snuck into the 2008
film marstar played the grass student
there and it's been suggested that this
is the same character as Mr Harrington
and MCU Spider-Man films which I love
burner says this in the beginning men
controlled machines now machines control
the fate of men a very burner her Z
sentiment but also it foretells the Doom
that Ultron will bring the Avengers in a
few months Hammer uses the Hulkbuster
rapid punch function on happy that Tony
uses on Bruce and Age of Ultron hul
happppy Roars a Sonic Blast knocking
Justin out the window he falls in a slow
motion shot that looks exactly like Hans
grber fall and die hard but I got to say
what made this great is that the call
back to the Rolex that Holly Gets as a
gift at the beginning of the film
earlier when Justin Hammer mentioned a
Rolex I thought they were setting that
up and there they go The Watcher wishes
us a good night with a ho ho ho because
it's the Watcher who sees us when we're
sleeping who knows when we're awake and
that's everything we caught in this
episode of what if happy holiday to
everyone thank you Eric for helping me
write this breakdown and taking just
time out of your really busy schedule
cuz I needed it go watch this breakdown
of Elf and die hard on the new Rockstar
Channel follow me at Lulu Clemens
everyone wish my awesome Mom a merry
Christmas cuz she's here with me thanks
for watching happy holidays and I'll see
you guys
[Music]
later
[Applause]
yeah hey
hey